wait what's that you have a question
perfect because this is ask ij i'll
answer all of your questions probably
won't answer them truthfully but at
least she'll get an answer hey hey
everybody's got a question on their
hi one announcement before we start the
show the winner of the ask ij10 contest
treat bag will be announced on
youtube.com otherwisejustine in a few
days or right now who knows go check and
see while we're on the topic of
youtube.com otherwijusteen if you've
been watching my vlogs you know that i
got a printer scanner which brings me to
the twitter question
eduardo carrillo
eduardo wants to know if i'll scan my
face don't have to ask me twice
sims 4362 wants to know if i don't go
out and party on a friday night what do
i do well actually it's friday night
right now when i'm making this video but
if i'm not making a video then i have a
dance party all by myself disco ball
please
hey justine my name is rachel are you a
kate sawyer fan or a juliet saw your fan
i saw your twitter today about lost well
before i answer your question on who i
prefer juliet and sawyer or kate and
sawyer let's get a quick example of both
parties hi i'm kate sawyer i love you
but i actually don't really love you i
just love your hair it's better than
jack's but i actually love jack a lot
more than you but i came back to the
island because i wanted to touch your
beautiful hair hi i'm julia sawyer i
love you so much that i just want to go
back in time and forget how much that
i've ever loved you because i know that
you actually really love kate and you
were just using me these past three
years that's all you were doing you were
just using me so you know what when you
let go of my hand while i fall down this
hole i am gonna remember that forever
and hate you
and now let's see what james has to say
on the topic
whatever you know the ladies want this
they call me james they call me sawyer
it doesn't matter because i'm the
destroyer typical as to which one i
prefer
i'm not quite sure
well that's it for ask ij episode number
11. be sure to follow me on twitter
twitter.com ijustine and
if you want to ask questions leave your
comments below make a video response
asking whatever question it is that you
want to have answered and even ask your
questions on twitter but be sure to add
the hashtag
sign
ask ij so that when i go back to search
for the questions it's there and i can
find it and i can answer it all right
i'll see you guys next time be sure to
subscribe um and you do that by clicking
the yellow button that's way that's how
you know when i have new videos out
okay bye
this is my microphone by the way